promesse historique de la gauche élargir
le droit de vote aux étrangers pour les
élections locales étaient la proposition
numéro 80 de François Mitterrand reprise
par François Hollande cette promesse
présidentielle devrait se concrétiser en
2014 une loi constitutionnelle a déjà
été adoptée en première lecture au Sénat
en décembre 2011 mais le texte est
depuis en attente à l'Assemblée
nationale à partir du moment où ils
vivent effectivement depuis assez
longtemps sur le territoire français ils
ont le droit de voter puisqu'ils sont
quand même représentatifs d'une grande
majorité je dirais de personnes dans les
béliers de nos communautés donc ils ont
quand même le droit et un mot à dire on
paye notre impôts nos loyers
ont subi la loi française pourquoi pas
admis à la direction municipales et même
pour le Président c'est vous pourrez
lire un président de la République dans
un pays il faut être de nationalité de
ce pays malgré que moi je suis d'origine
étrangère ça je le soutiens et je le
enfin j'en suis d'accord mais tout ce
qui est au niveau communal au niveau
municipal régional et tout je pense que
les habitants des quartiers les
habitants de la municipalité de la
région ils sont plus à même de délire la
solution pour être le concept de
réciprocité nous au Maroc les étrangers
par exemple les Français expatriés qui
sont installés au Maroc principalement à
Marrakech ils ont le droit de vote une
idée partagée par le maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il faut aussi
tenir compte de l'opinion des Français
et ne pas les diviser sur des sujets qui
ne les intéressent pas mais il peut y
avoir d'autres d'autres solutions aussi
on peut y aller de manière progressive
tout simplement dans la réciprocité ça
serait pas mal déjà que les Français qui
sont qui vivent dans un pays étranger
puisse aussi voter dans le pays étranger
à l'heure actuelle évoque la
naturalisation des étrangers afin
d'obtenir les droits liés par contre du
côté de Guyancourt c'est une évidence
les étrangers devraient pouvoir voter
aux élections locales et même pouvoir
s'y présenter comme candidat je pense
que des personnes qui vivent sur un
territoire qui vivent dans une commune
depuis plusieurs années qui payent des
impôts des personnes dont les enfants
partagent nos écoles des personnes qui
participent à la vie locale ça serait
quand même une reconnaissance et ça
serait une intégration supplémentaire le
député yvelinois Jean-Philippe Mallet
évoque les mêmes valeurs en faveur de
l'égalité c'est important que pour les
élections locales les étrangers puissent
voter ils travaillent ils contribue à la
richesse de notre pays et donc il est
important qu'il puisse qu'ils puissent
voter c'est un problème de de dignité la
gauche est déterminée à obtenir la
majorité nécessaire des 3/5 au Congrès
pour réformer la constitution reste à
convaincre une trentaine de
parlementaires